o lado diz pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos e mais um
vídeo eo estou aqui com aquele não só o
vídeo do giba em frente não sei se vocês
lembram mas o uma lágrima em que
catherine maquiou eu fiquei com isto
muda de figura
agora vamos passar um nível a accor mix
o filme focará chega primeiro
aliás desafio katrina provocar a filha
por gaza porque você é vítima nec mas
desta vez não vai ficar é uma pessoa
estranha superfície e essa não é uma
prisioneira lésbica borges domingo o
acto vai acontecer nesta primeira
cerveja vai ficar um homem lindo
resposta também não saiu eu já sou
solidário com portugal obrigado por me
ter se disponibilizado a esses
produtores são 40 do s amp p 500 estão
20 show não é muita coisa e ninguém se
pergunta então dá porque não estou para
fazer a maquiagem a catarina já que ela
fez ela distribuiu os pombinhos passaram
a cuidar o tenente portugal porque lá
está um vídeo onde sou eu a maquiar
catarina será que ela fez um bom
trabalho e vamos falar agora em estilos
o que vai fazer
basicamente eu vou realçar o que fez foi
mudar e foi para casa
vamos tirar o mérito foi a contar para
além do dark vão tirar as borbulhas de
smash dos sinais para eu ficar muito é
isso não diminuir a visibilidade do
esporte
o japão fica mais bonita isso
o momento não vai nem tá bom tá tentando
fazer
eu tô de cara minha técnica é tão lindo
agora estou legal
adoro um passo de rocha que está em uma
cor mais escura em uma das pontas e um
mais claro que basicamente vai fazer o
contorno da casa é eo ar livre de cara
ela ficar mais definida goste nós
cuidamos colocada pode fazer aqui nos
bicep isso aqui é um jogo de homenagem
do testo é assim ó espetáculo meu deus
já estou sentindo um músculo na minha
cara
meninas estão a sentir poderes são agora
nós que talvez chegar um pouquinho mesmo
assim é mesmo assim e já que abaixo
ainda falta mais linhas com meu deus
adoro o passe o pincel está em contato
comercial e banho de creme
acabou essa aqui é a mamãe do preço
vocês e agora catarina está a escolher
as duas coisas que importa aqui na cara
não é por este cara uniforme antes que
haja um absurdo nada pelas costas
de repente campaniço e ainda está
incompleto
este mesmo que vai nos dar bem estar dos
outros
a chance de ficar muito na minha família
pela primeira vez na vida a não ser um
homem também chora muito
seja como os conjuntos de boca acabou
fazendo dizer por cima do gol
chegou a um texto de um ano bom mas no
lado que tu fizeste da casa eu tô mais
fala eu pareço um vampiro a jogar muito
com o nicho em espera
estou me chamar de maquiagem nunca
fizeste primeira vez estou sendo um
campeonato e eu continuo com
profissionalismo
é como se eu fosse um e agora pra
educação anunciaram um problema é esse
mesmo potencial não pensam em manter
após saber como é que está eu gosto
especial quero fazer aqui mas sobre essa
linha homem levantando uma sobrancelha
homem mais a homem você acha que esse
palette chegando acha coisas é a cor
mais escura minha sobrancelha e preta
não o que estava escuro acho que aqui os
castanhos
ou pode usar os mesmos sonhos acha que
está em escurinho o sensus pena dar uma
olhada intensa e ele agora tá eu quero
ser um sexual - mesmo porque o lado está
o comportamento porque são pedro como o
da que tem esperança mesmo quem paga o
pato é o seu próximo show bonita nossa
ceni e não um ato muito na testa para
que desse uma olhada na época eu estava
com um dos olhos bonitos buscando o
empate mas quem entrar tem mais
ae
não sei se vocês sabem mesmo dado que
têm os cílios lixo em silêncio se uniu
ao ficar aqui por mais quatro casas de
pessoas que eu tenho que ser assim pra
casa um homem pode não só passar aquilo
tipo um batonzinho inverno frio eu tenho
este aqui por acaso que o jardim que é
uma coisa super leve em sua casa já
acabou
ok tem fera precisa por óculos é o dote
que assim um jogo bastante atrativo
vou entrar no q2 só vamos ficar por aqui
com espírito para que vocês tenham
gostado comentei em baixo que vocês
achavam se eu fiquei atraentes o que
todos parece um vampiro guy obrigado a
nike fronteira enviar estes produtos
todos para fazer um desvio obrigada
catarina cruzeiro minha maquiadora
profissional com um caso
tudo e se assim e isso é mais atraente
não esqueçam só a inscrição vocês vão
ter mais um vídeo que fiz pro canal
animax por isso acho improvável a
maquiar a corrida que é isso enquanto
nosso povo fique bem a próxima